what how you ever took a honey pack of
course right to the face what they work
nah oh my
gosh hey honey pack solid we be putting
just in the liquor you tried that no no
no put it in the Hennessy B that sh
Hennessy that [__] is going to have you
bent the heny will have me bent I'll
just do the honey pack straight up by
itself I don't need the don't do that
Gest no
[Laughter]
[Music]
more have you guys ever done the uh the
the the the gas station Rhino pills like
the Blue Rhino not y this try to gas
station die I if you go to the liquor
store Rhino pill they got the RH well
it's the same [__] as a honey pack it's
just it is no it's not the [__] that
[__] is unhealthy you going to die bro a
honey pack you're taking
perets no but that [__] is a right pill
you when you guys know you're going to
[__] a bad [__] for the first time do
you do a honey pack just so you can
press knock it out the park and home run
no you guys are so young you guys
shouldn't be doing this your rhino pill
is FY yeah that's for Old Men a rhino
pill yes yeah I'm 36 it's not this the
thing if you're drinking right all right
so how do Rhino pill like work like it's
like it's so look this way I look at it
if you're going to get drunk right you
got to have reinforcements so you don't
have whiskey dick so if you're going to
drink a lot you want to perform yo bro
[__] be saying that that feel me they
don't feel me they get turned on by the
[__] and they [__] be on feel me n as
soon as I see the [__] I'm ready bro
not you're muddy muddy Oh I thought you
said you was muddy I'm like what does
that mean bro tell me please what that's
that lingo too what about that muddy
yeah that's another lingo like yo as
soon as I see a [__] [__] my pants
bro it's real money dog get real money
[__] I Chuck the
deuce yeah but you've never had whiskey
dick where you drink too much and then
you're like hey you know I can't come no
no what hell
no yeah yo what the maybe it's an old
guy thing I don't know I got too drunk
before like I just shouted a [__]
faceing with the sleep what you sat on
her face n sit like sit in a bit like we
talk I like I'm just sing her face
talking go to sleep like not even [__]
sat on her face you sat in her face in
her face like we just chilling
like does that mean never happened to
you you have a you had a [__] come over
you too drunk y just go to sleep I've
never sat on a girl's face no I don't
sit on a girl n hey yo bro stop bro yo
stop bro I've never sat in her face
either hey did you guys see the video of
Kevin Gates spitting in the girl's mouth
on stage that [__] n v n he's VI gay
that's the grossest [__] I've seen don't
he have a wife no he just be up you know
his him and his wife have a complicated
relationship that I won't speak on
because I don't know the details but
they are very uh I don't know but I just
know that he does his thing you seen a
shorty shorty [__] when he punched the
fan yes I did why he punched the fan cuz
he was banging on him in the front row
PA I don't know I thought it was his op
or some [__] like well the dude was like
throwing up a bunch of sets to shorty
shorty throwing mad [__] [__]
shorty shorty rock this rocked him in
the crowd you guys shouldn't do that
some [__] licked them on stage I don't
know what happened like you never know
what happened ganger what happened um
someone lick you why you keep telling yo
why you keep telling people somebody
lick me that was a one time thing real
about that I was at a show I'm me feel
me I'm just regularly going to see the
fans and [__] going in the crowd I'm
walking dapping [__] up and [__] I
don't know it somebody my on the back of
my ear oh what the [__] was on your
shoulder you lying [__] it was right
here bro wait so a dude was it a dude
bro I
[Music]
feel me I turned around and everybody
cut everybody cut y got serious
everybody cut some dedicated
fans can you imagine how weird of a
human being you got to be to just go
lick a yo that's and wasn't we at a show
it was a show like you was
sweating what about this is my chance
I'm Li lick is crazy I don't know if I
ever see these guys again no no no
that's a little too crazy [__] probably
never watch his tongue you probably yeah
[__] probably say any any tattoos of
you guys huh four
tattoo we got four know what I'm saying
he fans yeah my son J just found a fan
titties did she get a tattoo uh nah did
you do anything else with the titties
after n hell no
she was
nasty I don't know just killed
the oh my God yo titties is just
like perfect titties is just the best
like I hate a [__] but no titties bro
like bad titties what about that bad
titties cuz like the titties can make up
for like if a [__] don't got a fat a
you the titties make up bro n you need
titties you just talk about this
sh
about you guys ask titty guys titties
titties titties it w't really be about
the ass really be about the [__] [__]
what about that keep tripping it's cord
what about I now it's better you can
hear me yeah it's just this cord's
tripping [__] cord